Ici, ce n'est pas très bien.
Rien n'est plus beau que le ciel de Paris.
C'est beau ce que je dis !
Je me suis ému !
[rires]
Ça fait très longtemps que je n'ai pas fait de vidéos de magie sur cette chaîne,
alors je te propose un tour de magie.
-Ca marche !
Je vais te demander de dire "Stop" en anglais.
Est-ce-que tu sais dire "Stop" en anglais ?
-Stop ?!
Oui voilà, c'est bien.
[rires]
Tu vas m’arrêter quand tu veux. Tu me dis "Stop" à l'endroit que tu veux dans le paquet.
-Stop !
Stop ici ? Alors tu t'es arrêté sur le 2 de cœur.
C'est bien ou tu veux changer ?
-C'est bien.
C'est comme tu veux. Plus haut, plus bas, ou on laisse comme ça ?
-Plus bas.
T'es sur ? Parce qu'on pourrait penser que je t'ai influencé à descendre maintenant...
-Non.
Alors, on y va ou pas ?
-Non, on reste.
[rires]
Tu sais quoi, je te repose une dernière fois la question, et j'accepterai ta toute dernière réponse.
On reste ou on change ?
-On laisse.
Ok, alors prends la carte suivante, tu la montre à la caméra, et je ne regarde pas.
C'est bon ?
-Oui, c'est bon Fabien.
D'accord. Alors je l'a reprends et on va la placer dans le jeu,
pas forcément au milieu du jeu, quelque part au hasard dans le jeu.
Et je vais retrouver cette carte avec deux indices.
Mon premier indice va me donner une indication sur la famille de ta carte.
Donc tend la main comme cela, en essayant d’être dans le champ de la caméra.
Voilà, parfait !
Alors je coupe ici dans le paquet, et je dirai à priori, que ta carte, est une carte rouge.
C'erst correcte ?
-Oui.
Si c'est du noir, sa carte sera du rouge. Si c'"est du trèfle, sa carte sera du carreau.
C'est bien du carreau ?
-Oui c'est du carreau.
Vous ne comprenez pas la logique du mentaliste, c'est juste ça le problème.
Je vais vous faire voir avec le deuxième indice ce sera plus clair.
Cette carte tu la garde dans ta main.
Et moi je claque des doigts et aucune carte ne va se retourner.
Et ça c'est pas facile à faire.
[rires]
Par contre, si toi tu claques des doigts sur le roi de trèfle, tu peux avoir l'illusion que le deuxième indice est plus correcte.
Alors, c'est ta carte ?
-C'est ma carte.
Et oui évidemment que c'est le 3 de carreau !
Et d'ailleurs j'ai un détecteur pour ça.
Si c'est vraiment ta carte il suffit de la remettre et de faire comme ton chiffre, bélier,
4 !
Pour n'avoir plus que 1,2,3 et 4 cartes !
Oups je t'ai craché dessus...
-C'est pas grave !
[rires]
Et comme j'ai voulu être sympa avec toi Jeff, j'ai fait un beau carré de trois, si je ne me suis pas planté.
-Bien Fabien !
Merci beaucoup Jeff !
Personne n'a applaudi...
[rires]
C'est la première fois qu'on m'applaudi pendant mes vidéos, alors forcément ça me touche !
C'est cool de t’être déplacé jusqu'ici.
-Rien que pour toi, bien sûr !
Je fais un pouce en l'air pour Jeff !
Pour cette vidéo moi je dis ça !
Merci à vous, n’hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air comme vous a dit Jeff.
A vous abonner à la chaîne et à laisser un petit commentaire, je lis tous les commentaires et je vous réponds.
Et on se retrouve demain à 17h pour un prochain MentalVlog !
Ciao !
-Ciao !